how's that a double Melissa
we are the newts family
[Music]
we've always been known as a large
family and we're also very close we're a
strong family of faith when we get
together it's 60 or 70 people I guess
when I think about my family I just
think I'm one of the luckiest cast in
the world I really do we're all very
close
[Music]
he went from worrying about our hands
being clean and what groceries we needed
to buy to a you know not even like a
week and a half later or mom's in the
hospital when we realized we're not
gonna be able to be with our mom
I don't see how she was unable to place
a children with what we had and for
everybody to turn out pretty good
she was devoted to the family you know
we had an alcoholic father who
unfortunately died an alcoholic
but mom was very strong and she kept us
together as a family where you think it
goes
but when she first went into the
hospital and we knew that we weren't
maybe a visitor it just really gave
everyone a sense of hopelessness and
helplessness that we wouldn't have
anything that we could do even if we
wanted to to hold her hand or to be with
her unless he figured out that we could
get a laptop to her a nurse at the
hospital came and met me outside and can
grab the laptop and within about an hour
it was up in room mom I think would love
that to be her last 24 hours it was like
a real party and one of the families got
to watch her and join her her Japanese
dinner and you know we even kind of
thought maybe she was gonna come around
you know watching her there on Sunday
the doctors had let us know that she was
most likely going to be passing soon
they were going to go ahead and minister
where they call comfort drugs so each of
the brothers and sisters had gathered up
each of their family members and then we
each were able to get on the house party
app and spend time with her as a family
unit I would say mom it's Tommy Tommy I
said I love you mom and she responded
back I love you and I cannot tell you
what that meant to me they had her an
oxygen mask they had a massive
discovered her face and oxygen was
blowing through that mask when they did
pull the mask off nurse was holding her
hand within less than a minute
she said she's gone
when they went to go remove that mask as
when the nurses gathered around her room
outside her door and the other nurses
held her hand so it was pretty it was a
pretty touchy moment for all of us the
hardest part of this for me is not to be
able to be with you long because we're
such a great support for each other
it feels a little surreal I know that
she was in the hospital and I I know
that she's not here but it also kind of
seems like was it just too dreamlike did
it really happen someone it just seems
like not real because you didn't see her
and we didn't all get together the whole
situation really just makes you feel
like you're being robbed of not being
able to hug your loved ones you know or
be with them or talk about you know your
stories about our grandmother together
you just never imagined in a million
years that this how it would play out
and this is this is how it would happen
[Music]